Hello everyone, this is Frank Defradis, and welcome to another broadcast of HoloTalk.
I'd like to welcome the new iTunes listeners who are tuning in for the first time to the program, and also any other podcast listeners who are listening through subscription programs such as podcasting.
While you're listening to this, you'll hear me start off on the telephone, and then eventually I move over to a microphone here in the studio.
So I just wanted to explain that little bit of discrepancy that you will hear during the recording.
It's actually a phone conversation between the two of us that happened to be recorded with Klaus's permission, of course, for the HoloTalk broadcast that you're about to listen to.
So without further ado, let's move on to this uh edition of HoloTalk, and I look forward to having you back once again for continuing shows throughout the rest of the year.
This is Frank Defratis, and thanks for listening.
Right now, as of now, I'm recording.
Why don't you uh tell me a little bit about what it is that uh th it's coming up for you?
Uh several things uh started already.
Uh uh told you about the um new technology we have developed here together with my partner Hanno Hanno Matizen.
Okay.
And he's also in holography for twenty years.
All right.
And and and work with all the guys and James River products and and uh crown rule leaf and it's just is this mostly with embossing.
Yes, mostly with embossing and kind of technology.
So we're setting up a a new very big plant here of um industrial production.
Maybe you should tell everyone we're here is here is a Hamburg, Hamburg in good old Germany.
Good which is uh Europe.
Big harbour city in the north of Germany.
Hamburg.
Yes.
Very famous for the Star Club back in the uh nineteen fifties and sixties.
Very close to me here.
I'm in the St.
Pauli area with my office here.
Is it still located there?
I imagine it must be a historic site.
Yeah it is.
No it's not lo and not uh uh the the the road is still it's called the cross of freiheit w where it's been as Beatles played and there's big music club right on the other side now but it's not opened as Star Club I see anymore.
But listen let me continue with this.
We we have developed some kind of very interesting uh technology uh mentioned which is the UV technology which is known already worldwide but we have modified it in a very interesting um way which allows us to more or less print holograms on any kind of surface.
Doesn't make any difference whether it's paper unrules or a textile or film.
That's incredible.
Yeah, yeah.
It's quite incredible.
It's and partial printing on it and and in a better quality than ever been before because yeah, it's possible to measure it of course.
But this is not what I wanted to tell you.
I mean another thing is maybe just to finish this what we are doing and what's coming up is also an R R and D project.
Uh which we we we got one together with the company where Frit Antisier used to okay the uh portrait pulse laser masters here in nineteen eighty six, also close to Hamburg at the old and famous Holocom.
The structure still exists and we also are working with it in with the machinery and RD projects.
So we get an very interesting R and D project by German government in cooperation with the university, two other companies and um the Fraunhofer Gesellschaft Fraunhofer Gesellschaft which is they have several uh locations all over Germany and it's in a private institute but uh very professional in R and D project.
They developed MP three standards.
No kidding.
Yeah.
This this is in an inven invention of a Fraunhofer Gesellschaft.
So we got a very interesting R and D project in holography which is explosive structuring, explosive copying.
Magnetic tape was invented in Germany as well, right?
Yeah, this is true.
Magnetic tape, yeah.
Yeah.
And but this is something I just wanted to tell you about what's going on and what's coming up here.
But actually I would like to talk with you about a cooperation and regard to something I've been planning for years and it's completely ready now developed, which is a Europe wide travel exhibition.
Okay, and this is a holography exhibition?
Yes, and all three D technologies and techniques available uh will be shown.
Not only holography, but just a course through history of holography.
Yes.
And from the beginnings of stereograms and stereoscopy and and and lenticulas and three D movies up to present technologies and future technologies, three D the data storage and three D projection systems and of course w one of the largest travel exhibitions ever been shown.
So we are going to show it in in Hamburg, in Berlin, in London, in Barcelona, Paris, Paris, Milan, anything else?
Amsterdam And what are what are the dates for this to begin?
The date is um two thousand and six.
The the the the main time will be two thousand seven.
So it's um I see uh sixty years of holography.
You know, Dennis Garbert worked and he published his work in forty eight but he worked forty seven he worked in and and he self said he developed and made that ex that tests in nineteen forty seven.
Yes, I I've always quoted nineteen forty seven instead of forty eight, but I always see forty eight printed.
Yeah.
But it is it is um uh it's been published in forty eight yeah his work.
This is w as far as I uh have um checked it out.
So, um and I am preparing a curatorium we call it over here.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
No, I do not.
A curatorium a curator curator, which is an arts when you you know a curatorium Oh yes.
Exactly now, yes I do.
And this is what uh we are preparing, and I'm um involving one friend of mine who is a design professor at the Hamburg University, Gunnar F.
Gerlach is his name, and he will be one of the curators and write something in the in the catalogue.
Mm-hmm.
And we have a very interesting collection available and together already.
The German um it's a optical company and and glasses, uh uh chain, shop chain called Feelmann.
He's got a huge collection, the Feelmann collection.
Yes.
Of holograms.
And I'm also in in contact with the MIT museum collection.
Okay.
And would like to involve and invite you as well.
Well thank you.
In w what capacity may I be able to help you?
Um, first of all, I would think to um to just be member of the curatorium.
We are we are um g having uh probably eight eight persons maximum worldwide.
Mm-hmm.
And as I mentioned, the professor is one of them.
Another one is a worldwide active um artist and he's an architect who d who just did the the Spanish uh booth on the expo in Japan.
I see.
Yeah.
And he's doing very nice work.
He's quite famous.
He is doing and he will do the design with us.
His name is Ulaf Nuak.
He's living in Spain, but he's also German.
And um so and holo holography artists, of course.
I'm thinking about taking the other US American, I would like to ask um Dr.
John Perry.
Oh yes.
I think he might be in interested in just being member of the curatorium.
We will also look for uh for a budget from our sponsors because um there are sponsors in Basque, of course.
Mm-hmm.
Have to be.
I mean this is a very big project.
Yes.
And I have sent you the mail now.
So maybe maybe you can check in the meantime whether you've received it.
Yes, it's here.
Is it?
Yes, it is.
I haven't had a chance to read it because I'm speaking with you through through a microphone now with headphones on since we're doing the show.
Can hear it's a little bit different.
Yeah.
Do I seem how's this?
Is this a little bit better for you now?
Yeah, it's better.
Okay.
So the w the treatment, you uh have you opened the treatment PDF file?
No, I have not.
I d I don't want a chance losing the audio file that's being recorded on the computer as as we're speaking.
Okay.
But I will go in there and let's you know what?
I feel like living dangerously today.
Let me go in here and open this up.
Yeah.
I have to turn my head away from the microphone.
No problem.
And of course, since my eyes are so bad, I have to put glasses on now because I'm far away from the screen.
Wha what operating system are you using?
Oh, I've always been on Macintosh.
On Macintosh.
Apple, yes.
Yeah.
Very good one.
I see uh 3D Lab Hamburg presents Holo World.
The world.
The world of holograms.
Right.
Sixty years of holography.
Yes.
This is something that I can include on the uh website as a download for everyone.
This we have an agency involved already and uh have already partners, though there is um a meeting now of you do you remember National Geographics?
They did a cover in the eighties.
Oh yeah, sure.
Yeah.
Couple covers.
Right, a couple, right.
But I'm talking about the one with the with the McDonald's ad on the back side.
Oh, okay, yes, that's the one with the exploding globe on the front.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, the exploding globe.
I love it.
So um by by excellence they they heard about 'cause their web designer met me and I talk talk told him about the exhibit.
And now they are quite interested in doing something similar here in Europe.
Mm-hmm.
A cover and also some kind of uh uh articles and information about the exhibition and everything.
So um but this will be decided in Washington next week.
Okay.
The the um reduction the the the international um press uh national geographic people they they meet in Washington with because that's the the main office obviously.
Mm-hmm.
So is is there going to be any representatives there from uh your group?
No, they just wanted to have this this uh written thing, yeah, which you also can see here now, this treatment.
Yeah, because this this is at the moment uh in our agency is working on doing a uh uh official presentation paper.
I see.
That'll be done in German, you know, and then afterwards be translated into English.
But I mean you see it's starting in September two thousand six in Hamburg.
Yes, I see that.
So um uh you know, uh this is not that far.
I mean th we work on it with the agency, but this was a short English description I made myself.
It's very well written.
Is it?
Yes, of course.
I was not sure.
Thank you.
I really wasn't sure.
I was like, uh, can I give it a w away like this?
Because we are still working on it with the agency and doing it in very perfect and and and and better and more um detailed way.
And in in what capacity can I be of service to you?
First of all, I wanted to invite you to be part of the curatorium.
Yes, and that you know and what responsibilities will that entail.
Yeah, and I mean you have produced holograms as well.
Oh sure.
So and uh so we could show some of your work.
I also would like to show some of your work there.
Okay, thank you.
And and I mean this is in a way historical like I think.
So and uh and and you can see I mean there's a b a big list.
The consortium, this won't be lots of work for you.
Maybe um of course you can I think th there shouldn't be a problem to to put it on the website also, because it's it's that far already, you know.
Otherwise the only risk might be that someone else is trying to do something similar or so.
The idea is good uh people will love it.
And as you can see on the list of the first site on the first page, mm-hmm you can see I mean this will be a big area with a lot of things to see.
This is in conjunction with another tour, uh a larger tour that's just basically four three dimensional technologies in the history, right?
Holography is a subdivision of that.
No, it's mainly holography.
It's mainly holography.
Yeah, it's mainly holography.
And all the other things are subdivisions like three D techniques or or lenticulars or stereographs.
It's interesting to show them.
Yes.
And and and sh and give the people glasses and sho I will also do video projection.
I did that twelve or more years ago already here in Hamburg, uh, with uh with uh also in three D company in the U United States and those and materials with video projections.
But meanwhile such a lot of um uh um new technologies or many new technologies are available.
Oh absolutely.
And and it's unbelievable to show all that.
They showed at the expo a uh fear meter which is pff I don't know, hundred and fifty inches uh um uh screen, three D auto stereoscopic, auto stereoscopic screen.
Without glasses.
You stand there right in front and it's a depth of forty, fifty inches.
Oh that's incredible.
Yeah.
And I mean people need to see these kind of things, um I think and they like it, they love it.
I like it so pretty.
Any any chance of bringing it over to the States.
Actually, we have meanwhile so high level contacts there.
So um in Barcelona there's once a year now in June in two weeks starting, uh it's on the Zona Festival.
Okay.
Which is arts and media, media arts, international media arts, artists and musicians festivals.
And it's very high international.
Many Americans come over there.
And it looks like we can even be in Barcelona in in the same building area at the time of the Zonar Festival.
Okay.
In two thousand seven.
And this if this happens, we will probably get uh inquiries f uh from New York or the United States because the tour I mean there are Americans involved, lots of the holograms are uh made by Americans and and um but worldwide and Russians and Europeans so worldwide.
Yes.
Um so um I think this m might be might be possible, but I I I I don't think about it at the moment.
'Cause it's I mean, you know, uh the wor I think the hologram the show will be good enough to be on World Tour.
But first of all we do the Europe tour.
Yes.
We're living here.
Yeah, of course.
Mm-hmm.
I think it's I think it's it's it's great, definitely.
I mean I can I have I have an idea already, of course, and I know all all the different things, you know, you probably also will understand when you read it, yeah, what what I'm talking about.
Oh absolutely, sure.
So we have a pulse laser system, recording system.
Now what have what have you been doing with the pulse laser system over there?
Is there um is there a market for pulsed portraits of people or not that much?
Our our is is ours is not set up at the moment because we are we are preparing this big production plant with new technologies and uh here right now this year we are starting to build it up and and we have lots of equipment which is not completely set up at the moment.
But there is another friend of mine who who's who got the other uh in Germany, the other pulse laser system in south of Germany, Holowood is the company name.
Um Tim.
And he's got one, and I made with our system I made in nine with Fred Antisier eighty six we made Nina Hagen hologram.
Nina Hagen, you know her?
No, I do not.
She's a rock singer and she's often in the United States.
She was in New York sur recently, um normally living in LA.
Maybe my daughters know her, I'll have to ask.
Yeah, no problem.
Uh I'm an o I'm an old man.
Yeah.
So I mean, we all are a little, but I'm not old.
I I'm not that old, actually.
Uh I don't know, I even look very young.
People never believe me my age.
You sound young.
I'm I'm nearly forty eight forty six.
Ah yeah, in two weeks I'll be forty-six.
You have a very good sound to your voice for forty second d usually sometimes you can even tell the general health and vitality of people through their voice.
Yeah.
I don't think so.
Right.
But this always depends on my mood.
I mean I can tell you I can give you a l a link if you want to see if you're online still.
Yeah, I'm online.
Where am I gonna go?
Um then you can see how I really look.
But it's a little freaky picture page.
That's alright.
Give me the address.
Um go to HoloStar dot com D E.
Holo Star uh triple uh W W Wolostar.
Mm-hmm.
Um D E.
Slash.
Yeah.
Uh photos.
This is a German photos, which is F as in in fantasy.
Oh, okay.
F O T O S.
Okay.
H T M L H D M L I see I see your baby picture there.
Yes, that's me.
Oh there you are.
Look at this.
Hippy Clos playing the guitar.
Yes, that was when I was twenty years old.
Oh you're a good looking guy.
Oh.
I don't know.
Oh there's Nina, huh?
Yeah, this is Nina, the crazy Nina down there.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's got uh Fishnet stockings on.
Fishnet, oh yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, she's crazy, I tell you.
She's got a nice daughter.
Oh look at you, boy, you're having a good time here with some of these shots.
Oh yeah.
Are are these all recent pictures of you?
No, this a recent picture is done there that was in the studio, blah blah blah.
A recent is look at the last two ones.
Okay, yeah, which one?
You're on the one with the heart.
The w the guy the on the left, yeah.
White hand and and the with the heart.
Yes.
This is how I nowadays look.
Wow, and you're forty six, huh?
Yes, I am.
Wow.
I don't know.
That's amazing.
You you live uh you live a good life.
I I I hope to.
Good diet?
Food?
No, good food.
Biological food.
Yeah, good good healthy foods, right?
Yes.
Yeah.
That's important.
Huh.
Yeah.
Isn't that something?
Wow.
You could and that last picture you could pass for like in in your twenties, like a college student.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I always look like a like a baby face.
I can't change.
Maybe uh this is someone told me maybe and and he also he knows one in Berlin, a guy.
He he is looking like th thirty seven years old.
Yeah.
But he was born in nineteen thirty seven.
And he's got a son who is end of fifties with a beard and everything.
But uh his father looks like a son.
He said maybe it's uh uh genetic defect or something.
I don't know.
Wow.
You know grey hair or anything, huh?
No grey hair, no.
Yeah, I just started turning white a couple years ago and man, it's really coming on now.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm forty old as you I'm forty nine, I'll be fifty soon.
So this is fi we're going on to fifty.
This is what I'm also thinking.
The first pictures are so funny with the little child you know.
Me with fifteen months old.
Yeah.
With a screwdriver and and and and a plaque and and so this is Yeah, your second picture there, you look a little bit like an American actor we have over here, Kevin Bacon.
Kevin Bacon?
Yeah.
Uh huh.
In that second picture there, uh a young Kevin Bacon.
Huh.
Yeah.
That's beautiful.
Laser Master at Labor Holo Press.
La Labor, a label lab.
Laser Master Lab at Holo Press.
Holocom and Holo Press.
We were in Lübeck for a couple of years.
Yeah, some nice equipment in the background there.
Yeah.
Table, yeah, you see the holder and everything.
Wow, you're yeah.
Great.
So how's your uh your your partner is uh doing okay?
That's Hano Martisen.
Ah, you could I I'll show you something else.
Go to HoloStar DE again.
Oh the HoloStar.
Yeah.
Go right to the uh initial page, the front page.
Yeah, the initial page.
Yeah, okay.
You can also have it on the English home page, but it doesn't matter.
But you're on the German one now, yeah?
That's fine, yeah.
Um be entsteht ein holochram, blah blah blah.
Who got us now?
Uh here glaube ich.
Yeah, here.
Go on in the left upper frame.
All right.
There's written third position.
V entsteht ein hologram.
Yes.
How is a hologram made?
Yeah.
Click that.
Mm-hmm.
And then click Master Tish.
Okay, I see it.
Yeah.
I'm going there now.
Okay, great.
Can you there's there's Fred, huh?
This Fred.
Here, here we are.
This Fred and and then and the other one, this is my partner, Johannes Matisen.
Okay.
Hanno.
Everyone calls him Hanno in the worldwide business.
Hano, hello, Hanno.
Nineteen eighty six.
That was in nineteen eighty six, right.
I was just getting started with my own lab in eighty three.
Ah.
So uh Yeah, there was a big equipment, nice equipment, but it's all been stolen by German industry.
We could write really we could make a movie about this what all happened.
But very good that I finally reached you.
Yeah, you must you must have an interesting calling plan that you can stay on the phone so long from Germany.
What do you have?
A calling plan or something?
I just got a calling plan.
It is fine.
It is this is a Hanzenet, which is not the official German telecom.
They are quite expensive.
I mean they really cost us ten thousandths because we often in the past and eighties already at that time it really was expensive to make phone calls in the United States.
Through telecom like I don't know, six bucks a minute or something.
Oh god.
Unbelievable.
But um no no, this is much cheaper now, and these are long distance, I don't know, blu uh fibreglass line or or satellite.
I think this is a fiberglass line.
Yeah, the c the connections real uh it's a wonderful connection.
Just around the corner, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's just digital.
Okay, if you c if you could say anything to the folks who would be listening, you've heard these shows before on the web, right?
Yeah.
These Holo Talk shows?
Yeah, if you could say anything to any of the listeners, what would you say?
Oh what would you tell them?
Yeah, they're listening to you right now.
Oh they're not listening to you live.
I mean, I'm going to edit this and put it up.
But they'll they'll be listening to what we're talking.
And keep interested in holography.
It's still future and fantasy and as written in my in my concept uh about the Holo Show, you probably just have opened.
On top there, I would say holography is a true intersection of art, science and technology.
Which Professor Stephen Benton said once.
Once.
Yes.
I'm sure several times I'm sure.
Yeah, probably once.
Probably more times than you wanted to.
Yeah.
I will go into details and send you uh mail.
I hope it comes through this time directly.
Email or regular mail?
Yeah, no email.
Email.
Okay.
Yeah, that's the oddest thing.
Um you know, I should still have deleted email from uh 'cause there are some emails that make it through that are spam.
It doesn't get every one of them.
I'm gonna go back in there and see if somehow I uh I accidentally deleted that.
And you uh 'cause I always I always I always send email back and forth between people.
You know, I would never intentionally uh not send an email to someone and just let it sit.
I mean sometimes I let the emails pile up for a few days and then maybe on a Wednesday night or a Saturday night I'll sit down and answer all of them from the past few days.
You know.
Yeah, send send me if you I send you more information on the moratorium.
Yeah, and people can download that at the website.
Right right now.
I'll send I'll make it right now and send it in about five or ten minutes.
Okay.
Uh yeah.
So it's been good talking to you, folks.
Good talking to you, and and now you're a guest on HoloTalk, so look for my announcements when you're gonna be on there.
I will, definitely.
Thank you.
Thanks a lot.
Right.
Have a nice afternoon.
You too.
Bye.